pouvoir tous aimé revenu sur my friends
dont il ya quelques mois eu une vidéo
par bruce d'y penser sur y penser par
ailleurs sa chaîne secondaire oui du
chanteur plus en mode blog où il parlait
de l'absence de sources dansé dansé
vidéo
suite à quoi il ya une vidéo réaction
d'un de signification de xavier rist a
deux significations sur l'importance de
mettre des sources en vulgarisation de
cliquer dans il disait un peu l'opposé
de ce que disait brousse et a su de tous
a eu des discussions au sein de vidéos
science sur l'importance de ces sources
ou est-ce qu'il faut toujours mettre des
sources et j'ai envie de vous donner un
peu mon avis on vous fait en profiter un
peu de ce beau paysage normand alors les
sources en sciences s'il très important
tout article scientifique digne de ce
nom contient énormément de source et sr
bien sûr à remontrer à donner de la
crédibilité au message que quand on dit
en montrant qu'on n'est pas les seuls à
transmettre tel ou tel message puis ça
montre aussi que on a bien travaillé
donc on a bien lu la littérature d'une
certaine manière et que du coup tout ce
que l'on dit et je vais toutes les
opinions qu'on pourrait avoir ou même
tous les faits que l'on est dans ce sont
des opinions et des faits bien informés
et plus que ça en fait une bonne
habitude c'est une bonne habitude
d'essayer de montrer d'où vient
les connaissances que l'on a d'où
viennent les prétentions que l'on a et
si le très bonne avec des habitudes à
avoir quand on réfléchit de façon
générale parce que trop souvent il me
semble que lorsque l'on réfléchit on dit
des choses mais on sait pas pourquoi est
ce qu'on pense ce que l'on pense et
c'est un travail extrêmement utile de sa
d'essayer de lister les raisons ou les
sources en tout cas les causes qui font
que l'on pense ce que l'on pense qui est
probablement le truc le plus important
de du savoir c'est le comprendre
pourquoi est ce qu'on pense ce que l'on
pense
je pense qu'aussi c'est une démarche de
ne donner doté de deux quais de mettre
ces sources
en mettant ces sources on est vraiment
honnête par rapport à ce qu'on pense et
d'une certaine manière on se protège
ainsi contre des gens qui dirait que
l'on pense qu on pense sans juste parce
que on veut penser si vous ça ceci dit m
des sources ça ne suffit pas c'est pas
parce qu'on a des sources que ce que
l'on dit est vrai et c'est simplifier
beaucoup les choses que de penser que en
mettant des sources justifie nos propos
aujourd'hui il ya tellement de choses
qui sont écrites et dit partout que
surtout si on les interprète mal peu
importe ce que l'on pense
on trouvera toujours des sources qui
confirmeront ce que l'on pense qu'ils
iront dans le sens dans le vers lequel
on veut aller et du coup en fait
l'argument de la crédibilité et de moins
en moins valable il ya une étude qui est
sortir en 2013 si je ne trompe pas
marvel engine sun qui a étudié
on se rappelle les plus value c'est un
peu technique en gros à partir de son
analyse
il a prédit le fait que 25% des
résultats scientifiques publiés sont
faux
à partir d'une lise statistiques et ce
genre de résultat et vient confirmer des
dés l'augmentation de la non
reproductibilité des résultats
scientifiques
donc même des résultats scientifiques
même une grosse faute portion des
résultats scientifiques et surtout les
résultats scientifiques qui qui qui sont
surprenants et qui parle de sujets
d'actualité je pense que c'est c'est
beaucoup de ces publications
scientifiques sont fausses et du coup ce
n'est pas parce qu'on a des études
scientifiques en sources que notre
message est vrai ou non et c'est un des
gros problèmes avec le web aujourd'hui
tout cas sur moi c'est que les gens ont
tendance à s'enfermer dans leur propres
sources et du coup le disent qu elles
mêmes sources
difficile de reprocher à des gens qui
ont des mauvaises source de tourriers
avec même source parce que finalement
scientifique
moi je veux finalement je retombe pas
macho toujours sur les mêmes sources
je pense que quand on cite des sources
on fait toujours constamment du chao
picking en fait citer des sources c'est
faire du shopping c'est à dire choisir
des références sur lesquelles on va plus
se référer que d'autres que et le cube
fund picking
c'est super dur à éviter mais c'est le
pire des maux dans la science et il ya
une excellente vidéo alors vraiment
excellentes de la stricte une arête avec
john oliver à ce sujet dans le cas
c'était par donald huard ses prix sur
très gros parce que c'est une émission
de télé américaine où il des
nutritionnistes ou quelque chose comme
ça qu'ils doivent parler et puis laurent
est un gars qui dit la bonne façon de
vivre c'est sa vie c'est de choisir des
résultats scientifiques qui nous
plaisent dont acer ça c'est le picking
des sources dans le pire des cas mais de
façon plus générale je pense que c'est
se voiler la face que de penser que
lorsque on fait une liste citation à
profit la bibliographie grimper ça on va
être exhaustif ou bien représentatif ça
c'est pas les gars à chaque fois on fait
du tube picking en fait faire de la
vulgarisation scientifique assez faire
du shopping c'est choisir des sujets
dont on va parler plutôt que d'autres et
c'est choisir des sources qu'on va
considérer plus crédible que l'autre est
en fait bruce lui il fait de pas mal de
physique moche et des mathématiques
et je pense que dans ces domaines où on
a des déchets des résultats qui sont
établis depuis longtemps nos vidéos ne
cherche pas à promouvoir une vérité nos
vidéos priori cherche à expliquer des
idées établies et en ce sens je pense
que la nécessité des sources est
beaucoup moins évidente
par exemple sur cette chaîne vous ai
parlé de la loi des rechutes décor de
gailey de la relativité restreinte
d'einstein des lois de newton et quand
je vous en ai parlé jamais fait si une
fois mais en général je ne cite pas les
sources originales moi je trouve même
que c'est négatif que de citer de telles
sources
parce que ça donne ce côté pompeux et
chiant des sciences qui cherche toujours
à avoir raison qui cherche toujours à se
donner un air élitiste a compliqué les
choses plutôt qu'elle simplifiée est en
fait sur ce genre de dans ce genre de
cas un jour a tendance à être même
contre l'idée de mettre des sources du
cas des sources originales des sources
scientifiques
après quand on touche à l'actualité et
des sujets à plus catchy plus paranormal
voir et sciences sociales ou les choses
sont moins établie je comprends que les
sources soient plus nécessaires que
quand physique et en maths
dans ce cas on parle de l'actualité d'un
truc d'actualité il faut absolument
mettre les sources parce qu'il peut
avoir une propriété non négligeable que
la source que l'on site se trouve être
fausse vous réfutez ok bon comme vous
aviez rester à deux significations fait
beaucoup de zététique bien sûr pour cela
l'étude des déçus or c est ultra
important pour que nous prendre pourquoi
est ce que certains pensent ce qu'ils
pensent les sources encore une fois
c'est super important
bref tout ça pour dire que si on peut
mettre des sources ce n'est pas aussi
rassurant que ce qu'on pourrait croire
quant à la crédibilité des documents en
question fait je dirais que c'est pas la
raison pour principal en tout cas pour
laquelle je pense qu'il faudrait mettre
des sources
je vais sans doute remarqué que je finis
chaque vidéo tout cas chaque vidéo dans
le format principal je finis chaque
vidéo avec deux liens vers deux vidéos
de de vulgarisation scientifique en
général et je pense que c'est ultra
important de faire ça non seulement pour
rendre hommage et promouvoir les travaux
des uns et des autres en fait une autre
raison aussi que je trouve aussi
importantes c'est d'éviter absolument de
donner l'impression que j'ai tout dit
dans une vidéo
c'est quand j'étais amené au cast une
des questions qui surgissent et quelle
est la différence entre une bonne et une
mauvaise vulgarisation et moi je réponds
vue
je pense qu'une bonne vulgarisation
signaux violations qui donne envie
d'aller plus loin que de continuer à en
savoir plus de vouloir en savoir plus je
trouve quelque chose qu'il n'y a rien de
pire en vulgarisation scientifique que
de donner l'impression que tout a été
dit et que on peut passer à autre chose
c'est pour ça que j'aurais tendance à
encourager les autres youtuber
scientifique à finir leurs vidéos avec
au moins des liens vers leurs propres
vidéos voire des liens vers des vidéos
de d'autres youtuber qui piquent y parle
de la même chose de sujets connexes pour
vraiment donné l'impression que la
connaissance sais pas où je peux les
sciences ce n'est pas n'est jamais finie
quoi c'est une recherche dit souvent
qu'une bonne thèse si une thèse qui
soulève plus de questions qu'elle n'en
répond et je pense qu'une bonne
vulgarisation scientifique ça doit être
quelque chose de sites de similaire
c'est quelque chose qui doit amener à
d'autres réflexions savez je pense que
plus on avance en mathématiques et plus
on se rend compte que ce qui est
vraiment génial en mathématiques ce ne
sont pas les faits mathématiques c'est
toujours cool à une sélection de frais
mais ce qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool en mathématiques je pense
c'est vraiment les liens qu'elle avait
les connexions qu'on peut voir entre
différents domaines et pour vraiment
montrer l'impression qu'il ya que les
mathématiques sont quelque chose
d'unifier qu'il y ait vraiment un choeur
mathématiques et que tout ce que l'on
dit contribuer à ce coeur mathématiques
je pense que c'est vrai aussi aux
surnoms en sciences en général c'est là
que la beauté c'est dans ces connexions
là il faut favoriser pour mettre en
avant ses connexions la saillie dans le
cerveau aussi ce qui fait la la
connaissance enfin tout ce qu'on sait
dans le cerveau d'autres savoirs de
prouver tant c est tout du tout où
réside non pas dans les neurones mais
dans les connections entre les neurones
et moi je pense que une vulgarisation
qui sera de très très grande qualité
c'est une connexion c'est une
vulgarisation qui sera extrêmement
connectés et je pense justement qu'en
créant des liens rentrer des vidéos
scientifique a priori différentes
contrées un cosmos microcosme de vidéos
scientifiques dont la qualité dont le
l'intérêt tran semble de loin la somme
de ses parts c'est pour ça que j'aurais
tendance à vraiment encourager les
autres scientifiques les autres youtuber
simplifie a toujours finir leurs vidéos
avec des liens vers d'autres vidéos bon
blast et c'était marie forcé now est ce
que ça veut vos avis comptent au moins
autant que le mien du coup je vous
invite à mettre vos avis dans les
commentaires